what I'm learning from most of the
science YouTubers is that they are like
us there are two science type YouTubers
or building or engineering whatever like
the the unhinged type and then like
macrobat type yeah they're like we're
professional we do everything above
board and then you have all right let's
just explode things let's figure it out
let's make a gun out of tampons
the worst thing is like they all come up
with crazy things on their own but when
you get these science guys together it's
horrible I got the zoo like we were we
were staring staying at like an Airbnb
with a bunch of them together and you
win backyard side to yeah just pretty
much destroyed the entire house like
within within within five minutes they
caused this explosion in the backyard
well I know within five minutes I had
stabbed Kevin backyard scientists
by accident because we were in the house
we were trying to we hyped each other up
and the house had locked doors like
every Airbnb does right and we were like
oh let's go lock pick all the doors and
just see go rubbish through them through
their possessions like [__] horrible
people and in the process of trying to
lock pick I was using a knife to she
made the lock open I slipped and just
stabbed Kevin straight in the arm and
just went straight through his thing
just hit his bone and this was after
five minutes and we had this moment
where we stopped and looked at each
other and were just like why do we do
this like how do we get here like how
did I stab you Kevin yeah exactly the
same brand of add it's like and then you
just you enable each other yeah yeah
it's pretty bad yeah it's like when you
see like dog a dog looking into a mirror
and they're like
you made like his own rocket fuel yeah
Kevin he's like what Kevin's like the
person I want to be in terms of like his
level like he's incredibly smart and
just hyper focus on something and just
make ridiculous inventions like his
Tesla coil that plays music and yeah I
thought I've never been a spiritual man
when I saw Tesla coil I thought I saw
God
he was crazy have you guys heard them
playing music yeah yeah yeah yeah oh my
God and when you're in the same room as
them it does something where the air I
think is charged yeah so you feel like
you know your skin is literally has
goosebumps because there's static
electricity like pulling your hairs out
of your body yeah I uh I I recently like
played around with the Tesla coil
because I I was hanging out with this
Japanese YouTuber who's basically the
equivalent of what you do about Japanese
what's his name uh Sushi Ramen yeah yeah
unfortunately yeah yeah yeah so like he
has a Tesla coil as well and I went to
his place to just hang out with him make
a video and he was like like oh let's
try and cook marshmallows with a Tesla
coin and so we're just standing there
holding this thing while this Tesla car
is just burning the [__] out of this
marshmallow and yeah as you said like I
felt my entire body just like get
electrically charged and I'm like this
is not safe yeah like I should not be in
this room right now yeah so is this a
homemade Tesla coil uh yeah yeah he had
like made a Tesla coil and I was like is
this safe and he's like well I'm not
dead and I'm like that's not that's not
a guarantee at all that's not that's not
a good barometer considering uh yeah if
he doesn't know what he's doing with
electricity like you said yeah but it's
a bit of survival of the fittest you
know if he's if he's lasted this long
that means there's a filter and he's
he's passing it yeah have you ever had
to do any like studying for like or just
like upping your knowledge for whatever
I talk [__] about myself a lot but I
have I have gotten a bit better at
making things in terms of like welding
and machining abilities right it's nice
and that now I can actually
work with something break it down and
turn it into parts that are usable and
having the ability to like just turn
metal into like bolts and threads and
cut stuff is pretty cool because you can
actually look at something like well I
can make all the parts to this just with
metal at home right and then learning to
weld is is nice because it's just so
strong and it's actually people talk
[__] about welding a lot we're like oh
you have to do it in this right way it's
like no you can just kind of get a stick
and go like this and it does just hold
together it's like it's nice how did you
come up with your ideas for what you
want to make or like your new videos
because it's sometimes I'm like okay
that kind of makes sense you know with I
look at Michael Reeves and I'm like okay
there's some logic there's it's like
batshit crazy logic but there's some
kind of logic and sometimes I look at
your videos I'm like what the [__] are
you trying what are you trying to
achieve what are you trying to improve
here I I think it's usually starting
from one place that's logical like
something will uh kind of spark a bit of
like a question in my mind right some
just something I've seen in the world
old or something someone says and then
you just kind of go from there you write
that idea down and then you just twist
it a little bit or tweak it a lot of it
comes from me thinking oh what would
people on YouTube like what's
interesting
um like I can open my life in danger
yeah I feel your videos are kind of like
the questions that like hi people like
ask each other except you make it a
reality yeah I feel like there's gonna
be a lot of videos where both of you
have been like we should make this and
you're like oh this is a terrible idea
we should not do this
coming up with the boy boy ideas is fun
because it's it's really like just like
I don't know trying to push like
political questions or things we're
interested in but you're like oh how can
we turn that into the political yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah like I saw you I I
don't know if this ended up being a
trend but I saw you snuck into like an
arms dealer convention or something it
did it did get a bit of a bit of people
doing the same thing you weren't talking
about that and we had a lot of people
just make the exact same video yeah yeah
because I saw that one video then my
YouTube recommended was like oh I snuck
into a security convention I sluck into
an ex-convention I don't know yeah which
is very easy it was crazy when I was
doing it yeah it was so easy but like I
assumed that it wasn't gonna work I'm
like of course it's not going to work
why would I be in there
um no one checks it so what what was the
process of like sneaking into this um
well I mean I was staking out the place
quite a bit I was thinking like do I
like jump the fence do I do this and
what I ended up doing was um after the
first day all the kind of arms dealers
had posted on Twitter being like I'm a
fun day at the festival and they had all
their lanyards there I'm like okay I
know what the lanyard looks like I'll
kind of copy it but for legal reasons I
couldn't copy it exactly because that's
like fraud so I just it was called land
forces and I just called it fake passes
and um there's like a QR code on there I
just put on a random website and I just
walked in and I think it's one of those
like and you get scanned and no one
checks anything and you go straight
through and it's just like I think the
way it works a lot of the security there
are terrified of you because you're some
like hot shot arms dealer like you know
you're gonna get them fired if they hold
you up too long
like you could potentially work for
Boeing yeah yeah like you're not going
to say no I think it's just like it's
just like confidence is like the biggest
part of it and like it is crazy like you
belong yeah I think the coffee is a big
trick coffee like walking in with a
coffee and a suit like people are gonna
be like that man belongs here he's late
and he's grumpy and he's tired and he
needs to be in a meeting it's like a
modern day equivalent of what the hive
is yeah yeah it's exactly it it's like
No One's Gonna question you like and the
[__] is also nice because you're
terrified in there and you always want
to shake and when you're holding
something at least you've got something
to do with your hands
did you get any did you get any Flack at
all for doing that or was it all just no
that was all fine I think that the nice
thing about arms deals is that like
everyone hates them
um
that was a that was an easier one
all right so you've learned how to
launder money how to get in any
convention is there any other life hacks
you've learned from making your videos
what have we done what's something that
like you've figured out through your
videos that you're like this is [__]
but it's commonplace yes all the money
laundering yeah obviously that one I
don't know like you know I forgot every
video I've done yeah
I think I've watched all of them or most
of them
um I think a big thing that from boy boy
is just how easy it is to to lie as any
kind of media company or or what what's
considered like a fact yeah that when
you actually look into you're like
there's no real information there's
nothing in there nothing behind it and
people don't realize that whenever
they're hearing a story there's an
agenda behind it yeah yeah it doesn't
matter which country's saying it there's
always something like that so it's like
yeah yeah I mean it's because like
objective news is boring you know yeah
it's boring and people don't want to
read it and engage with it well a lot of
time so you need to like I guess spice
it up and we do the same things as
YouTubers because you need to like
sensationalize our thumbnails and titles
as much as possible yeah yeah is it was
there any concern with when you're
making videos about like maybe
Australian politics because you know
like um friendly geordies right uh yeah
you just know who this channel is yeah
yeah it covers a bunch of Australian
politics and the kind of the corruption
stuff going on and they fire bombed his
house yeah discussing well you don't
know who right uh but there's good some
good ideas about who it probably was
um but yeah I mean the dude got his
house they try to kill him yeah is there
any kind of like hey maybe we should
maybe not so we did our money laundering
video with him he was like the original
guy who exposed it yeah yeah and like
potentially they fire bombing because of
it I don't know yeah I can't say who did
it yeah the fire bombing happened so we
filmed the the timeline was we filmed
with him right then two days later
before we released the video he was
Fireball yeah and then we had to make
and
she was so chill about it she was like
oh thank you this is great I'll hang it
up in the shoe cupboard I was like do
you do you know why I'm it's this is in
case organized crime yeah
it's like yeah I know it was it wasn't
quite scary like yeah yeah but I think
it's you know we were lucky that he
friendly geordy's exposed it first yeah
took the heat hopefully literally
and then we were just like yeah it's
happened now you know are they gonna
Fire Bomb another YouTuber
but he was so lucky as well because like
he was they were he was meant to die
like because he was meant to be there
he's someone organized that he like
forgot his keys and he had to go stay at
a friend's house something like that
yeah it doesn't make any sense I mean
the thought that the YouTuber could be
killed or murdered for just talking
about [__] politics it's so crazy
yeah to that point where the YouTuber
has that much influence that it would be
a problem
I think what it is is that like
journalists aren't doing their jobs like
no one's reporting on this so the only
one who is is this YouTuber's gonna get
[__] I guess because there's so much
you know with a lot of journalism
um there's a lot of money yeah that is
what's going on right the young people
who really don't have any someone to
answer to is just a random YouTuber yeah
I'll put my patreon
like this is weird that it's come to
this where only independent journalists
can kind of really go after the stuff
and afford to yeah although to be fair
after the um fire bombing I think his
subscriber count like doubles
a little suspicious
I was a good video I watched this video
where he was like who who firebombed
friendly jordies it was a great video
yeah it was a really good video where
it's all laid out about it it was a
really interesting style he's a very
impressive man like I don't understand
if I got fire bombs it would probably
end my career I'd probably start yeah
just like so so determined yeah it's
it's very important because he also had
like one of his producers got arrested
right yeah yeah yeah yeah this was like
a whole big thing as well like a year
ago or something right yeah they I I'm
not too familiar with it but it was kind
of a crazy thing where he was he was Pro
uh reporting making videos about uh
prominent political figure yeah yeah and
then they got like the terrorism or
special terrorism yeah it's a fixated
person's unit yeah to arrest his like
producer so bad it's just like what the
[__] is this it's just the funniest
response when what you're doing is
pointing out corruption and then in
order to fight back like we're gonna do
the most corrupt thing to you right yeah
I'll sell to corruption
you think you've proved our point I mean
it's really impressive that uh yeah I
mean I I it seems that a lot of Aussie
creators are no matter what gets thrown
their way they're just like [__] it
that's just the Aussie you wear right
it's like a very Aussie response they're
trying to ruin your life you're like
I'll just do it more yeah
thank you